it was a somber ceremony in heavy rain
police officers carried the coffins of
their four colleagues killed in a knife
attack on Thursday Paris's police
headquarters by a man who'd worked
alongside them for years investigators
say the attacker had been radicalized
after converting to Islam
the French president called on the
nation to be on guard against what he
called dangerous ideas let's come
together and stop this Islamism stop it
deadly ideologies that ignores our laws
rights of life police say the killer was
45 year old Mikhail harp on a computer
expert who worked for the police since
2003 most recently in the Intelligence
Unit French media report that
investigators searching his home found a
USB key containing the names and
personal addresses of hundreds of police
officers the president of France's
National Assembly has called for an
investigation some of the attackers
colleagues say they raised their
concerns about his behavior with their
superiors but that they were ignored the
French Interior Minister has admitted
failures in procedure but he says there
were no warning signs at the newsroom
for the attacker was someone who was
relatively well regarded his qualities
were noted there were no signs of
radicalization this man didn't hide that
he converted to Islam but it's not
because you're a Muslim that you are a
terrorist to parliamentary committees
questioned Kasten air over possible
security lapses some opposition
politicians say he should resign it's
politicians who must take responsibility
it's clear mr. castaigne is not doing
his job in terms of security politics by
not telling the truth and not giving
police the means they need to work
police union leaders in France say
morale is low and officers are
increasingly the target of public anger
and assaults but few police officers
could have imagined that someone within
their own ranks could have turned
against them so violently natasha butler
al jazeera paris